it is the best day ever and so is
yesterday and so is tomorrow and every
day from now until forever I think a lot
of people are sitting down here today
and being like I didn't expect to feel
that way I didn't expect to feel so much
I think is the is the thing that's
taking Everyone by surprise some things
have been happening that might be
related
cold shower falling off my roof
And my heels
are on the ground
[Applause]
even when you were crying I was like
what is she pulling from because she's
literally a doll cry we haven't played
with Barbie since we were like five
years old I mean for some of the more
funny crying things I remember like
looking at how little kids cry and
they're like the faces they make like
when I cry my cry face is kind of
different tell like you know a little
kid in there like the lip comes out it's
like comical it's kind of funny and
you're like oh but you almost want to
provoke it because it's so cute I'm
coming with you okay
planning a doll is actually a very weird
acting task
um I mean especially a doll that doesn't
want anything
yeah like how to activate that it was a
real head squash hey Barbie
can I come to your house tonight
there's a lot of like childlike Dynamics
I think between Ryan and I Albert
Lincoln sometimes were more like
siblings or like he was more like my
child to the mother you know there was
like different kind of Dynamics like
that that I was trying to pull from in
in like a you know help guide me in that
path but we had the freedom because of
the script and because the greatest
direction we had the freedom to be like
really really big with the comedy and
really really grounded with the drama